you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up from wildfires to
flooding voters go to the polls in
australia with climate change high on
their agenda
the worst drought in decades sees the
number of people in east africa facing a
hunger crisis double in a year
and on a royal visit to canada prince
charles calls for an urgent move to a
green economy after the russian invasion
of ukraine
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world hear from
the people being hit hardest by those
changes and report on the race for
solutions
now this weekend australians will go to
the polls after several major weather
events in recent weeks severe flooding
in parts of the country has damaged
crops and destroyed lives this year and
consumers have been warned to expect
food price rises while just two years
ago huge wildfires ravaged large parts
of the countryside and the wildlife
population
all this has put climate action high on
the agenda for the australian public
but with an incumbent prime minister
reluctant to act
smaller climate-focused parties have
seen their popularity rise adele
robinson reports
sitting on the frontier of a climate
crisis
australia
towns swallowed by floods
[Applause]
bushfires scorching the earth and with
an election looming voters desire for
action has a new sense of urgency
climate change never used to be
considered as a kitchen table issue as a
sort of run-of-the-mill everyday issue
but when your kitchen table's now
washing down the street you realize it
is a really a kitchen table issue so the
hyper concern i think
is because there are a lot of people in
a lot of the country who are feeling
quite scared
but recent analysis of social media
coverage shows little to no focus on
climate by the main politicians
opposition leader anthony albanese or
prime minister scott morrison the bits
in yellow show the number of tweets that
actually mention it
make no mistake
climate change is here now
any policies brought up have been
described as scant on detail
the major political parties have been
really trying to
downplay climate as an issue uh trying
not to mention it too much when they're
asked about it they sort of recite these
very uh like
uncontroversial uh wrote lines about it
they're not really introducing major new
policies we'll keep on mining of course
we'll keep on mining and that's partly
why australia is a major coal exporter
the economy's a priority but it means
independent climate campaigners may tip
the balance of power you have our
pacific neighbors that have been the
voice of reason on climate action and
have been calling on australia to
increase its targets and to stop
expanding fossil fuel production and now
it's facing this challenge at home
domestically from these independents
that have climate as a front and center
priority and is challenging in their
heartland seats in sydney and melbourne
recent floods formed the election
backdrop that's now widely seen as a
rapidly disappearing window for
meaningful action adele robinson sky
news
let's get some of the day's other
climate news now and a new super nature
reserve is being created across 15 000
acres of the somerset landscape to
protect salt marsh heath and wetland
habitats natural england has announced a
new somerset wetlands national nature
reserve in an area home to rare and
threatened species the move brings
together six reserves and is going to be
the second largest area of lowland peat
in the uk
eight wild cat kittens have been born at
the highland wildlife park in scotland
and are likely to be amongst the first
to be released into the wild saving the
species from extinction in britain the
project led by the royal zoological
society of scotland plans to release the
adorable kittens in carefully selected
locations in the cairngorms national
park next year
jamaican singer and rapper sean paul has
told sky news that he's seen the effects
of climate change first hand and is
trying to do more to stop coastal
erosion in jamaica in an interview with
sky's beth rigby the musician said he
was speaking to experts on how jamaica
could restore the country's coral reefs
which have been affected by climate
change
very sad to say right now that there's
no more beach
and and it's shocking when i remember it
as a kid
and so i'm seeing it firsthand there's
no more beach it's now the water is now
where the shacks are i've seen
uh work in dubai or
places even in the states in manhattan
where they're
putting things in the water so that carl
can grow back on it
um and i've inquired into that people
that scuba dive tell me that you know
it's it's really about the temperature
so so
uh it's a lot about that so i'm trying
to find some ways that we could do that
to help the coastline to be retained
and you can see that full interview on
beth rigby interviews in around 20
minutes time and beth will also be
speaking to the u.s ambassador to nato
julianne smith and the president of
sinfain mary lou mcdonald that's on beth
rigby interviews tonight at 9pm here on
sky news and catch up every friday on
sky showcase
now the worst drought in decades which
is causing a hunger crisis in the horn
of africa is reaching catastrophic
levels according to the un and other
humanitarian charities a report by save
the children and oxfam warned that one
person is likely to be dying every 48
seconds in the drought-ravaged region of
east africa
the extreme weather coupled with rising
global wheat prices and food shortages
has left livestock dead and forced
people from their homes
well this drought is affecting millions
of lives across the horn of africa the
report says nearly half a million people
across somalia and parts of ethiopia are
facing famine in kenya three and a half
million people are suffering crisis
levels of hunger
and the number of people across the
region suffering extreme hunger has
risen from 10 million in 2021 to 23
million today
and while the war in ukraine and global
food price rises are contributing to
this crisis climate change causing
extreme weather conditions was already
having a devastating impact
with industrial nations struggling to
reduce their carbon emissions enough to
limit global warming desperate
communities are left looking for ways to
adapt to their changing environments
well let's get more on this joining me
now from rome is the associate vice
president of program management at the
un's international fund for agricultural
development donald brown donald brown
thanks so much for talking to us
to begin with to what extent is climate
change responsible for this
this hunger crisis in the horn of africa
good evening uh it's uh at the heart of
the um crisis in the horn of africa and
it's compounded by
as you said in your peace the war in
ukraine and the impact that's having but
also the impact of covid people in the
horn of africa are facing three
concurrent shocks but climate change
clearly is the long-term most important
and what we have to do is adapt uh but
as you say there's about 25 million
people in the horn currently affected
and situation will get worse
and what's the main problem that it's
causing
well uh
the main problem is the crops are dying
in the field people are not able to
plant and if they do plant the crops are
withering and as you say livestock
is also being sold because there's not
enough water or fodder for them um and
this to say is made worse because we do
have many farmers we were talking to one
in somalia last week that does have
irrigation systems to be able to water
her crops but with the uh war in ukraine
and the increase in fuel prices she can
no longer afford the uh petrol needed to
fuel the pumps for the irrigation so
even though she has a solution she can't
use it because she can't afford it
so what can be done about it especially
given the fact that climate change at
the moment set to get worse are there
agricultural
methods that can be adopted that might
be able to help mitigate some of the
worst effects
there's a lot that can be done about it
uh we have the technologies we have the
solutions here uh it's all based around
adaptation adaptations of climate change
uh the big problem is investment or lack
of it about 1.7 of global finance for
climate is going to adaptation and small
farmers who are the most affected um but
as you say and i was in kenya last week
talking some of the farmers
we need to move away from growing uh
very very uh
difficult crops like maize that are very
prone to drought um and move to things
like indigenous crops like sorghum so we
have lots of drought resistant crops and
we need to move people to growing them
we need to invest in irrigation systems
that will conserve water and provide
crops to the very very changing rainfall
patterns out there and so there's many
many ways we can do and we need to
invest in early warning systems uh
because if rain comes farmers need to
know when it comes so they can plant in
advance and rate and and whether uh
information systems are very very
rudimentary in this part of africa so
there's many things we can do if the
investment's there currently the
investment is not there and we have to
really get it there otherwise it will be
a com become a problem for everyone
because if people cannot make
livelihoods in these regions they will
move to other ones
donald brown thanks very much indeed for
your time we appreciate it
thank you
now prince charles has used his royal
visit to canada as a chance to raise
efforts to tackle climate change through
green initiatives alongside the canadian
prime minister he took part in a
roundtable discussion on sustainable
finance where he said the war in ukraine
had hastened the need to move quickly to
a green economy skies rihanna mills has
more
there is no doubt that the prince of
wales wanted to use the profile of this
royal tour to once again
hammer home the message about the
climate crisis and try and encourage as
many people from the business community
to get on board because ultimately he
believes that business holds the key
when it comes to making a really
dramatic difference so he convened a
meeting of a sustainable markets
initiative you may have heard us talking
about that before
basically he's using his leadership his
convening power to try and get some of
the most powerful people
in the business world round the table
and properly get them talking about
solutions but what was interesting is
that he was saying in front of the likes
of prime minister justin trudeau who
he's he did praise and he has met on a
number of occasions before at cop26 at
the g7 summit um saying how it's now no
longer enough just to tweak the way that
we work or the process is in place what
we really need now is ingenuity and
innovation now in terms of getting his
message across of course there is
nothing better than actually going out
there and seeing the impact of the
climate crisis and that is exactly what
he is going to be doing later on today
we're flying about four hours north to
the northern territories where he's
going to meet the deter indigenous
community who basically most of the year
rely on an ice road but that has been
seriously impacted by warming
temperatures so in the past that ice
road that links the small debtor
community to yellowknife would be
operational for about 140 days but in
recent years it's dropped to only 90
days
and i think for the prince of wales he
just really wants to emphasize that
actually it's often the poorest most
isolated communities in the world that
are really having to deal with the
catastrophic impact of the climate
crisis
do stay with us coming up i'll be joined
by dame julia king a member of the
climate change committee and john
verdieck director of international
climate policy at the nature conservancy
and we're going to be talking about the
power of people to influence politicians
as australia's prepared to vote plus
we'll talk more about what can be done
to help alleviate the hunger crisis in
eastern africa
[Music]
we're trying to do something different
with this show
we interview interesting people from all
walks of life so you can hear that yeah
i hear right now but we're trying to
interview them in a way that it's a
conversation they jumped out and said
are you mr shuri and i said yes then we
want to try and understand what
motivates them it's very important that
nobody should say that we're trying to
avoid scrutiny thoroughly enjoyed that
thank you
i'm there to ask questions that people
want answers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
well there's a real sense now that
people are beginning to expect that this
whole airlift is coming to an end and
they're really really desperate
we saw snatch squads going in grabbing
people and putting them into trucks
[Music]
either live and recover
or you die
okay so that's like a war that's the war
yes
we help you understand the world with us
over the past 24 hours the soldiers have
been attacked on a number of occasions
[Music]
it's really sending a clear message that
venezuela is eager for change
we've been crushed
to take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
they were convinced the united states
would become hooked when they were right
when norma's sixth it's just come down i
think it was a monster just landed in
between us
the information on this could bring down
the entire network not just in iraq and
syria but across the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news now getting
straight to discussing the climate
issues of the day now with climate
change committee member dame julia king
and john verdick a director at the
nature conservancy so good evening to
both of you good to see you
so let's talk a bit more about global
food security after the warning from the
u.n secretary general this week that
global hunger levels are at a new high
and that the number of people facing
severe food insecurity is doubling in
the last two years to reach
276 million today
so john
how much of a crisis would you say we're
witnessing when it comes to access to
food around the world and to what extent
is climate change having an impact on
that crisis
climate change has always been a threat
multiplier in a way um you know and
we're seeing in eastern africa this is
an area that's it's always been
vulnerable to to different changes in
weather and drought and now we're seeing
climate change exacerbate that and i
don't think we really know exactly how
far this is gonna go and and what other
changes are gonna make but we are seeing
you know this was already starting to
happen before uh the invasion now we're
starting to see ukrainian and uh and
russian exports change we're seeing
other countries that are big importers
they're gonna have to change some of
their policies as well um
one of the worries that we would have is
to see if if we're gonna have more
countries that are actually gonna come
out and have export bans um that would
change the global trade system and could
have even further consequences well yes
and julia as john was hinting there the
war in ukraine is having a massive
impact on
food security as well isn't it and
is it the case that if the west is being
affected by shortages of food they're
more likely to see the whole issue of
food security more clearly and there's
some hope that action might be taken
across the world
i think you're right i mean i think
covid and empty supermarket shelves in
in the uk
uh and now the war in ukraine uh i think
they are reminding us all
that um that you know the security of
our supply chains is at risk
and it's very much at risk from climate
change of course
and it's something that we on the
climate change committee flagged up to
the uk government you know in a uk
context that we need to be focusing more
on our supply
on our supply chains and their and their
sensitivity to to climate change our
overseas supply chains um but it feels
terrible to be worrying about you know
us in the uk when you hear what's going
on in in kenya and ethiopia at the
moment well that's right and john that's
really a priority isn't it when people
are dying of hunger so what action can
be taken i mean obviously tackling
emissions when it comes to climate
change the hope is that will have a
longer term effect but there's real need
now
absolutely you know there's a real need
for food there's a real need for we we
heard earlier adaptation is going to be
a significant piece there we need to
build more resilient food systems um in
in many parts of the world um we just
saw the other day too i think we just
saw the g7 come out and say that there's
going to be a new global alliance for
food security um one of the nice pieces
that comes out of this sort of thinking
is not only is there money going now to
help provide food around the world but
there's also thinking of making sure
that we're not just producing more but
that we're building a more resilient
system that can absorb some of these
shocks better in the future
and julie we heard from our un guests a
bit earlier saying there are
methods of adaptation available there
that can make a difference but funding
is a real problem i mean
where will that money come from to help
people in in poorer countries
uh and you're absolutely right funding
is a problem and that was one of the
things i think that came across very
strongly at
cop26 was um the you know adaptation is
really the poor relation compared to
mitigation in terms of funding um and
you know we need to make we need to
develop better investment propositions
for adaptation
but we also need to see the developed
countries putting more money into
supporting adaptation in uh particularly
in the global south
john do you agree it's it's richer
countries need to step up
absolutely i mean we're six months out
from cop 26 in glasgow this last year
and we're six months from the egyptian
cop this coming year we saw lots of
pledges
from public and private sector
interests looking forward to what we can
do on climate now is kind of one of
those times that we need to make sure
that these investments are hitting the
ground that we're implementing these
projects for the people that are on the
ground
global food security is also a huge
trouble when we look at ramifications
that could eventually come out we think
about a decade ago we had the arab
spring
many of those issues were brought about
from food insecurity and and inflated
prices and we make sure that as we go to
cop 27 in egypt next year in sherman
sheikh that we are doing exactly what we
pledged we would do last year julia very
briefly though is that a tough ask when
there are countries struggling with the
cost of living crisis around the world
in the uk obviously it's been in across
our news daily
um
i i don't think it is a tough ask i'm
you know the the the rich world and we
are part of the rich world needs to do
something about this and
um you know we also have our own
problems of of distribution but we don't
actually have a problem that we haven't
overall got enough money in the uk to
help in situations like this
okay let's move on to our next topic and
uh from destructive wildfires in 2020 to
extreme levels of flooding a few weeks
ago australia is becoming increasingly
aware of the effects of extreme weather
and while there's widespread public
support for climate change action it's
something missing from the discussion in
the build-up to this weekend's general
election
so why is there a mismatch between
public opinion and politicians
perspective and is this affecting
campaigners ability to shift the dial at
all
julia some polls show that climate
change is the number one issue for
australian voters does it surprise you
then that it's
barely mentioned
by the politicians
it seems really shocking to me but i
suppose for the labour party in
australia you know that the the sort of
shadow of julia gillard's problem with
her climate tax that became so deeply
unpopular and is you know is accredited
with leading to wherever it is they've
had 13 years of of the uh more
conservative government i i think that
kind of hangs over the politic of the
politicians there and they're very
worried about pushing too hard on it
which is very unfortunate
john do you think this tells us anything
more broadly about the power of public
opinion in in driving policy when it
comes to climate change
yes uh you know i i think public opinion
can kind of go in two ways especially
with politics and the politicians tend
to listen to the people that elect them
but they also need to be putting forward
some pressure as well too and what we're
going to see
you know from some groups it's think
about australia it's a little bit
similar to the dynamic that's happening
in the united states where you do have
different political parties with
different views
we are going to have electoral cycles
where we're going to have more climate
ambition or less climate ambition
one of the things we need to do is make
sure that not just at the federal level
or at you know the national level but at
all the different local levels we
possibly can to be pushing climate
action to be pushing environmental
action and dealing with these um
with these elements as much as we can
everywhere
and you're in the house of lords julia
so you're in a unique position to kind
of assess what a driver of policy change
is what role do you think that public
opinion plays
well i think because australia voting is
compulsory in australia i think the
public there are actually even more
powerful because politicians have to
recognize that uh
every one of them well almost every one
of them will actually vote um so i think
that actually sort of adds to the the
sort of um pressure the public is able
to put on but i think we do see public
opinion um providing pressure in the uk
i think it's what's um it's what's
actually kept the fact that we still
have cross party pretty much prosperity
agreement on delivering the climate
change act in the uk and i think that's
hugely important
what about other pressures john i mean
what about global pressure international
pressure some it's like cop where
countries can be named and shamed and
look like they're standing out on their
own is that really what matters to the
politicians in charge at any one time
i think most politicians you know their
first thing that they listen to is the
domestic electorate um but beyond that
there is international pressure as well
uh just before cop 26 it was looking
like australia was not going to come
forward with a new climate pledge a new
nationally determined contribution but i
think we saw some international pressure
um coming forward and many other
countries coming forward with their new
ndc's and then australia did put a new
uh ndc out now they didn't change the
number in it um they didn't change the
kind of ambition of their pledge but
they did add additional information
saying how they were going to do it in
what ways this is the kind of thing that
you know transparency publicly and
internationally around climate change is
one of the most powerful tools we
actually have and i saw you nodding
there danger did you want to add
anything
no i was just agreeing i think there's
very good points
well on that on that that note of
agreement we will leave it there then uh
thank you both very much indeed for your
time really interesting to get your take
on it thank you
thank you thank you very much to stay
with us coming up next on sky news beth
rigby interviews guests including the
u.s ambassador to nato julianne smith
the president of shinfane mary lou
mcdonald and the rapper sean paul so do
stay tuned for that
but that's it from me thank you for
watching
[Music]
[Music]